I want to tell you guys something
you see the project Veritas expose the
other day it's it's like this morning
when I wake up and I'm doing my morning
segment the fir I'm I'm watching the
video again because we watched the night
the other night
I just went on YouTube and I looked up
90s commercials and I was like I'm just
gonna like 15 minutes of commercials
from the 90s just to just to remember
the good old days when there were no
troubles and I'm I know my parents
probably had troubles and there was war
and stuff but I was a little kid so I'm
gonna watch these commercials forget all
about it that was so disturbing
that this Dean was talking about how
they were giving these kids these adult
objects teaching them how to use them to
spit on them and things like that anyone
I can't even say it because you might
have kids in the room
and so I started uh I posted on Facebook
and here's the funny thing
what do you think the response is from
the left when they hear the stuff do you
think they go wow that's a bridge too
far for me I better rethink what I'm
doing no they say well he doesn't seem
at all worried about it the school seems
to stand by it it must be okay and I'm
like bro are you kidding me
as long it's it's like that that uh
that's this this I forgot I don't know
what you'd call it but the story about
when there's a fire in a room
if one person is a room by themselves
and smoke comes through they'll they'll
they'll go to the door feel the door and
go hey there's smoke there's a fire
though yell but if you have multiple
people in a room the smoke will go under
the door and everyone will look at each
other look confused and then ignore it
because no one's doing anything it's
like these collectivists can actually be
shown a video of a man bragging about
how cool it is that they're doing these
things to children well but nobody's mad
about it so it must be okay right and
that's just like if you're a person a
leader of strong moral fiber you're
gonna be like no I have a line that's
that's beyond for me I'm sorry
that's why we have a senate that's why
we're supposed to have a morally
righteous Senate uh says maybe that's
why they say that this this government
can't last without Christianity in it
because we need some group of leaders
that are critical thinkers that can see
it when it happened you know see like
disillusionment when it rears its ugly
head there's a couple things I want to
say about this story but this is a
family-friendly broadcast and I'm going
to save those comments for later you
know what what's your response to stuff
like that I mean you're in the political
world right uh do the voters see stuff
like that does it affect them or is it
as Tim says they see it and they're like
whatever
I I think some people
are tacitly approving of it because
they'd rather not rock the boat they'd
rather not
get into Political debates and and I
think that's wrong and and what Tim just
said really shows the necessity that we
have to speak out against it especially
we were just talking about this earlier
this book to people who don't know
genderqueer is in schools across the
country and we've had principles we've
had school boards fight to keep it in
schools and it says things that I would
never say to a child let alone my mother
or other adults I think quite frankly I
would consider this child pornography
and this is in our schools and what
people don't know
they don't know what they don't know and
I think if people did find out that this
was in our schools that they would be
horrified and that it would actually
motivate them to get involved and I
think we saw that with Virginia and
Governor Glenn yankin Etc but you know
even for myself I was thinking
what is My Philosophy when it comes to
being a conservative or republican or
just a I consider myself a freedom
nationalist you know we've been hearing
people say Christian nationalists no I'm
a freedom Nationalist and usually what I
say is people should be able to do
whatever they want in the comfort of
their home
consensually and legally so long as
they're not abridging or infringing on
the rights of anybody else right but
then I thought to myself but when you
use the word legal well there have been
horrible policies that have been legal
in the past and because it was legal
people use that as an excuse to continue
on with it you know should we introduce
what is moral what is ethical and I
think that's the conversation to be had
as well because some of the things that
are happening in America uh like the
Patriot Act for example uh just because
it's legal does that make it right yeah
a lot of the back of the blue people
need to also realize you know a lot of
the worst atrocities in recorded human
history were illegal and when they say
I'm just following the law I'm just I'm
just doing what I'm told they're going
along with some of the worst actions
that have happened to human beings
whether it's slavery the genocide the
Holocaust you name it all of that was
codified by law so so we need to really
start seeing things from a different
perspective a lot more people are
becoming Godless uh I I think that also
is maybe having an effect on this I I
never believe the government will be
there to solve any of your problems I
think they're only there to create more
problems in your life so how do you
enforce that in a way without using
government is is a question that I think
a lot of people should be asking
themselves is there is there a solution
without you know big Force big
government doing this for us usually
social ostracization like if you can get
people ground up to believe in a
morality but they control the culture
and they and they're pushing people to
not be religious they're pushing people
not to believe in a higher power above
themselves this is why the left calls
people white supremacists I want you to
think about that story uh Gore melts you
guys heard the gore melt story out of
Fredericksburg VA there's uh during
covet lockdown the guy who owns it says
I'm not doing this you can't shut me
down that's unconstitutional Bravo good
sir Matt Strickland and
uh eventually they say okay then we're
gonna we're gonna shut you down we're
gonna take your license from you so he's
in this dispute it's two years later
basically and they go into his business
the police to serve a search warrant and
give them a suspension or whatever and
try and shut them down
what do you what how do you how do you
deal with cops like that well the left
figured it out you call them white
supremacists why it's one of the most
repugnant things you can call someone
it's also inactionable if you call
someone a white supremacist you cannot
they cannot sue you because it's an
opinion and what does it really even
mean the the the term is is nebulous
perhaps on purpose but for the average
voter they know what it means it means
something
so if you have cops come into your
business they do this to you well my
idea was shun those cops right make sure
those cops can't buy a cup of coffee in
that town and if they ever want to eat
food again they'll have to move because
they've violated the rights of a good
hard-working businessman who is just
trying to keep he's trying to feed his
family keep his business operating serve
the community and the cops wanted to
violate the constitution so The Simple
Solution non-violent civil disobedience
is if you got a business in
Fredericksburg watch the video of those
cops and then put up signs in your
winner saying you are not welcome here
turn around here's the issue how do you
make sure in a large city like that that
you you can stop people from supporting
those cops well if you go around and try
and explain the nuances of why they
violated the Constitution how they
violated the Constitution and why
someone should support your efforts to
Bar those cops they're going to say look
I have no time for this I have no idea
what you're talking about I don't know
what that means and then you go
they're white supremacists the guy's
gonna go oh okay they're not welcome
here then that simple that's why the
left does what they do they don't want
to waste time explaining anything to
anybody it's too long it's too
complicated no one cares they simply say
this guy is a Nazi and if you support
them you know what happens and they go
okay you got it the appeal to emotions
I'm trying to emotionally get someone to
be afraid of serving them emotionally
that's that's why they do it because
it's the fastest and easy way to get
someone barred from from a business get
their bank account shut down get them
banned from social media
it is a functional tactic
my knee-jerk reaction is I I you know
again I haven't thought this through but
I don't think maybe we should be using
the same kind of policies that they used
and I think there is some kind of
government we should keep serving these
cops and let them eat a burgers at our
restaurant I'm not saying that I'm
specifically uh going about using this
kind of mass generalization and again
what I haven't thought this through just
call them just call it yeah I said
that's why the left does it I know we'd
do it I say we have to shun them from
our businesses but the reason they use
these terms is because it's very
difficult to explain in complicated
politics well I was actually considered
using the tactic because like you were
saying earlier we use the tactics they
use if there's ever like a competition
of something if you don't you're going
to get snowballed so like you you kind
of have to use the same but then when
they start using evil underhanded
tactics you're like the ends don't
justify the means not in every system I
got it do you guys know where the word
uh rape comes from like the the root of
it what it means no
so obviously in modern society it means
you know typically a man forcing himself
on a woman though in modern times it is
used woman on men as well but there's a
reason why the phrase raping and
pillaging is together because it used to
refer specifically to Barbara swords
going into a village
destroying it and stealing everything so
that was raping The Village was to take
all their stuff but in the process like
the Vikings for instance they would take
women with them and that's how it went
to to get this specific meaning in
today's day and age but uh if if
semantics is all we're really talking
about then those cops raped that guy
right and then you could say there
here's here's a cop he's a rapist
well that's what rape means right the
traditional definition if you want to
play Fight Fire with Fire and play those
games that's the that that's the game
they play
now here's here's my issue I agree right
I don't like those tactics I don't want
to live in that world I don't want to
live in a world where people are just
saying things to mean something they
don't really mean because they're trying
to trick people
but how do you and I mean sincerely I'm
not saying we should utilize those the
tactics of manipulation I'm saying how
what what is the counter
to those manipulative tactics in a way
that we can stop bad cops from like
raiding businesses like this
I mean I I'm kind of guilty I just did
it today I posted on my Instagram you
know some tweets of mine uh criticizing
uh Joe Biden freeing The Merchant of
death to Russia and I said on my
Instagram account Joe Biden is a Russian
asset I I don't believe that's trying to
trick or manipulate uh I think it's true
with the Nordstrom 2 and uh and with his
policy of trading terrorists for
Americans because it's going to set
precedent but I think it's a duality yes
we need to do those tactics as
truthfully as we can because look at the
end of the day we live in a world where
information travels so quickly that
people just want to be the first at
everything and it doesn't matter whether
it's true or false they just want to be
the first because it means that
information is going to travel as
quickly as possible globally but I think
Ian and I uh well hopefully everybody at
this table would agree that 99.9 percent
of of people around the globe are good
decent human beings but it's the 0.1
percent that is the loudest minority
which seems to be in control because
they're able to say those terrible
things about others and so many are
unwilling or maybe unable to speak uh
against them and I think that we need to
lead by example yes speak out but also
lead by example with conservative policy
with passing conservative legislation
and showing people uh
an alternative an alternative to what
the Democrats have been using against us
and let's show how we can do it in a
righteous and virtuous way and to give
you an example look at uh look at
Baltimore everybody was having this
conversation about trash in the city but
nobody was doing anything and so I said
okay I'm gonna go pick up trash and it
was that one action which spurred others
to go wait a second I can do the same
thing why are we going to wait for the
government
to come in and save us we can do it
ourselves and that that one action of
mine empowered so many people to believe
that they could do the same and I think
that truly is part of the answer lead by
example
so to answer I guess that and what
you're saying like a boycotting these
cops which I'm not necessarily agreeing
with but it is a way to deal with the
situation of people of cops over
overarching their Authority like just
one restaurant manager at a time one guy
tells one guy Word of Mouth rather than
trying to lie about these guys and to
fame them just be straight up they came
in they they shut they shut down an
aspect of my business against if it
actually violates the Constitution or
you know we could just take photos of
them and put up wanted posters saying
that there's Pirates going around town
and destroying people's livelihoods and
business and that technically is not a
lie too right it would say not wanted
because they don't want them no no no no
or beware pictures of Beware uh Pirates
running around shutting down businesses
on beheads of uh bureaucrats yeah as
long as these guys will do whatever it
takes uh to screw you over if they have
to you know I think even those beware
posters might be something maybe I
should just put up a bunch of billboards
all over Fredericksburg with their
pictures on it that could be yeah that
could be well you can do that that's
free speech so uh if I put up a bun if I
put their photos from the video on
billboards and then put do not serve
these men in your establishment they're
bad cops that's my free speech it's not
actionable and I and Billboard's cost
between a couple hundred and a couple
thousand dollars depending on where they
are why don't we just set a budget and
put those those Billboards up all over
Fredericksburg Virginia yeah I'll make a
phone call first thing in the morning
that's absolutely one way of doing it uh
doing Flyers passing out flyers being
like hey you know this is a community
effort here I I think also meeting with
the community meeting with uh the
restaurant owner and the the other
businesses and other people of that
community and seeing how they want to
handle this too uh creating a
relationship with them and and having
them come together when something bad
happens I think is also something that
could be incredibly strong and
Incredibly powerful of people saying hey
we live together we're in the same
Community together there was clearly a
state that committed a crime and a
violation against a private Enterprise
and a private business here that was
serving the community let let's come
together and let's act together and you
might not even have to buy a billboard
it could be posters it could be a you
know just a piece of paper with the
photos photocopied put up everywhere on
on polls yeah with diplomacy you could
get together with the restaurant owner
the police chief and then maybe have a
conversation publicly where they realize
we are going to reinstate the liquor
license that was a bad move and we're
not going to do it again that would be
better than just smashing at people that
made you angry and then they're gone and
now new people are going to keep making
the same issue over and over again you
got to go after those guys and like well
no no no no no no I think I think I
would put the Billboards up and I'll
just put beware dirty cops and I'll put
their pictures up on the billboard
warning
they would have to you know think twice
if they're going to do something like
that that's true historically cops would
not mess with people in their own
environment they'd have to bring police
in from another state or from like the
government from like a state government
because local cops don't mess with their
friends and family like those are your
neighbors and for good reason and that
kept things in order when you know the
cop had to come down and deal with a
brawl it's like listen we got to stop
the fight break it up guys look your
dad's gonna be pissed I don't want to
deal with this now they bring in cops
from Two Towns over and they walk in and
say don't know don't care pull the taser
just jab the guy in this instance it's a
guy who was standing up for his
constitutional rights and two years
later they're like we're gonna destroy
your business okay those are dirty cops
I'm sorry that that is they're like
don't know don't care well you probably
have to so you know someone super
chatted what about The Thin Blue Line
and protecting us from chaos yeah if
like in New York a dude steals a school
bus and is ramming people then like I
got no issue with the cops like that's
that's I agree like there's a reason why
we have police officers for situation
equations of like a guy running around
with a gun but we're talking about a
dude who is who's operating a business
that sold beer and the only reason they
went after his liquor license was
because he said Fu to their
unconstitutional edict the cops want to
enforce that okay they're dirty they're
dirty cops and uh you know maybe maybe
I'll just put up Billboards dirty cops
and I'll and I'll and I'll put them all
over the place they protected Walmart
they protected Costco they allowed all
the businesses with connections to
politicians to stay open McDonald's you
could walk in there get whatever you
wanted no problem but but this guy who
had a small business had to be shut down
by these politicians now years after the
these edicts because a politician went
to police officers and said go enforce
this and the police officer said yes sir
I'll do it right away and and all these
back to Blue guys need to face the
reality because the National Security
State is being turned around on the
people of America it used to be that
they were fighting you know terrorists
but that again don't even get me started
on all that but but you know you do a
lot of positive activism that you just
mentioned in Baltimore is there a way to
turn this situation and do some kind of
positive activism here with this well I
wasn't even thinking that way well I
agree that we need to keep it to the
individual and you know make it known
that we're we're not painting with a
broad brush and yes we do support the
police but we don't support the police
when they are choosing as individuals to
enforce unconstitutional legal mandates
but groups like black lives matter and I
want to make it very clear I don't
support black lives matter but if they
were smart they're working all of these
conversations seem limited to short-term
goals if I were a part of black lives
matter and I really wanted to make a
difference I'd say join the police force
become a policeman because then you are
going to be the enforcer of the laws
that you are for or against right and
same for us as conservatives when we're
calling out uh the sexualization of
children within our schools well a
long-term approach will be become a
school board member become a city
council member and become a teacher
become the solution to the problem
you're talking about in the law long
term that would be more my positive
activism as to actually try to solve
this from a long-term perspective thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time